express the area of a rectangle with
length 4y and with two Y as a monomial
so the area of a rectangle is just the
width times the height or the base times
the height now here the base is 4y
so let me just write down area it's
going to be equal to the width of the
base times the height the width is 4y
and the height here is 2y so it's going
to the area is going to be 4y times 2y
now here we can just use the associative
and the commutative properties of
multiplication so just swap the order
that we do this multiplying in instead
of multiplying 4 times y times 2 times y
we could say this is the same thing as 4
times 2 times y times y and of course 4
times 2 that part right over there is
just equal to 8 and then Y times y well
that's just Y squared or it's Y to the
first times y to the first which is also
Y squared so it becomes 8y squared so
that's the area and it's a monomial this
is a polynomial with only one term